more infants are entering the clark
county foster care system than ever
before the department of family services
really needs your help to try and find
safe and loving homes for these children
bianca holman is live this morning with
some words from foster care parents
about what this really means for our
community bianca good morning to you
good morning so clark county
commissioners they have declared may as
foster care awareness month and it's a
chance to highlight the desperate need
for foster parents there are lots of
kids entering the foster care system and
they need homes
this year there are more babies in the
system at a faster rate than before the
county wants to get ahead of the problem
by encouraging loss of vegans to become
a foster parent now so that their infant
ready foster homes later on this year we
spoke with henry aquino he and his wife
became foster parents in 2008 and since
then they've helped more than 30 kids
depending on
the gravity of the situation and however
long you have them
when that moment comes where they give
you a smile or
they laugh with you that's when you
realize that you've gotten their heart
and mind and hopefully it improves from
there
and towards getting them back to their
home
now the county also needs more care for
larger sibling groups families with
three or more children the department
wants to keep those sibling groups
together and also there's a need for
homes and for parents and families that
can take on children with special needs
as well of course there's information
listed on how to become a foster parent
on the clark county website there
reporting live bianca holmen live local
now